yesterday we talked about radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene being banned from twitter for her
fifth strike spreading disinformation
and i uh uh told you the details of it
and we mentioned you know when these
things happen it's of course correct but
they immediately turn it into i'm the
victim they immediately throw out their
principles of businesses should be
allowed to do what they want as long as
it's not illegal it's the same tired
routine and now unfortunately it's
scaling up even more because marjorie
taylor green has been suspended from
facebook just hours after the twitter
ban this one does not appear to be
permanent
um the congresswoman claimed data showed
the covid19 vaccine was unsafe marjorie
taylor greene the right-wing
congresswoman famous for her support of
conspiracy theories about the 2020
election coveted 19 and other issues has
been temporarily suspended from facebook
hours after being banned permanently
from twitter the congresswoman confirmed
her suspension in a telegram post
calling the company's decision beyond
censorship of free speech sorry beyond
censorship of speech her suspension
appeared to result
from the same post that got her a final
fifth strike from twitter which led to
her account's deactivation a post
claiming that vaccine injury and death
reports gathered by a reporting service
operated by the fda proved that the
government was ignoring large numbers of
deaths resulting from the vaccine now
that's untrue of course in reality the
data used by the congresswoman contained
anecdotal reports unverified by the fda
clinical trials have shown the vaccine
can have mild side effects and a handful
of serious side effects that are much
rarer
ms green originally posted a message on
both platforms pointing to a large
number of reports of injury or death
among covid vaccine recipients as
evidence that the federal government was
ignoring high amounts of coveted vaccine
deaths
this has become you know a favorite
among the anti-vaxx people now um i'm
really obviously she deserves to be
banned the ban from twitter is permanent
the ban from facebook is temporary
i'm conflicted only in the sense that
these bans are correct
but immediately used to the advantage of
these individuals and we can't really do
anything about that i mean when people
misunderstand what free speech is when
people misunderstand what censorship is
when people
claim to hold values of businesses being
able to do what's best for them
until it conflicts with what is
convenient for them
um we can't really do anything about the
fact that people like marjorie taylor
green will weaponize these bands
but now comes the onslaught of the
right-wing pundits confusing
the constitution
with
the terms of service of a private
company
um here comes the martyrdom
and the entire thing will she say this
violates hipaa i don't think so she's
known for talking about hipaa but i
don't think she will actually pull that
here
but this all plays into the narrative
and for all we know some of these people
maybe marjorie taylor green
are deliberately breaching what at this
point they have to know are the terms of
service of these companies in order to
get banned in order to claim that they
are being censored to their base so that
they will raise money it is after all an
election year now in 2022.
obviously marjorie taylor green and her
ilk deserve to be banned from these
platforms i'm not contesting that at all
but they have started to use these bands
almost like purple hearts in the culture
war
she was banned from twitter she it's the
equivalent of i went and i fought for my
country in this case her side by
tweeting disinformation and they banned
me
and the ban is held up almost like a
purple heart medal in their mind they
love being what they call persecuted
and they immediately start fundraising
off of it and it is after all
10 months until marjory green's marjorie
taylor green's re-election election
and um
it is
i i
i'm not saying don't ban them i'm merely
reminding everybody about the ways in
which they will immediately try to
benefit from those bands
and marjorie taylor green i mean in all
likelihood is going to sail to to
re-election easily we'll look at some of
those poll numbers for her
on friday
it's not going to make a difference in
that sense but they see these as
worthy injuries sustained in fighting
the culture war
that they have created one other really
funny thing is
facebook has been like a primary source
of not i don't want to say source
facebook has been a primary disseminator
of covet disinformation
by allowing so much of it over the last
year and a half and it's funny that now
all of a sudden they're banning marjorie
taylor green uh for for exactly that
reason but uh they did ban her it's
temporary she'll be back on but i expect
the fundraising emails to go out very
very soon saying they banned me give me
money so i can fight for you and medical
freedom and all this different stuff